(logo swooshing)
- Hello, believe nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going
to solve all the major
problems of the world.
So to help you on your
journey, today we're
going to talk about seven ways to get your
clients on board with value-based pricing.
And, as always, guys,
if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, please leave
it down in the comments below, put quotes
around it so other people
can be inspired as well,
and when you write it down, it's much more
likely to stick with yourself too.
Enjoy.
- [Announcer] Nine, eight, (techno music)
seven.
- So a common problem with
a lot of entrepreneurs
is they're not getting
the money they deserve
to get for the value
that they're putting out.
And they have a hard
time, one, charging what
their worth, which could be a
topic for a whole other video.
But two, getting the
clients that are the right
fits with them, who understand their value
and are willing to pay them for it.
So today, I'm going to
share with you my seven
ways on how to get your clients aboard
with value-based pricing.
(upbeat music)
My number one strategy is don't.
I don't try to convince
my clients of anything.
It's very rare to find clients who start
with you at a really small level and are
willing to grow with you
and pay you more and more
and more and more.
It can happen, but it's very rare.
This is why selling to
entrepreneurs is usually
a really terrible idea,
because, I love entrepreneurs,
and it's a rough business
model for most people,
because entrepreneurs don't have money.
So as much as you may love
the cause and the business
and everything that they're up to,
they don't have the money
to be able to pay you
for what you do, and
even if they do value it,
they value your experience and expertise,
they don't actually have
the money to pay you for it.
There'll be other people
who have the money,
but they don't value what you do enough,
and so those aren't ideal clients either.
Instead of wasting your energy trying to
convince people to spend
more money with you
or that you can provide
the value, I would rather
invest my time prospecting and
working with ideal clients.
And so I don't really try to bring clients
aboard with value-based pricing.
I try to go out and find the clients
that are already attuned to it,
and work with those people instead.
(upbeat music)
So that takes us to step
two, which is define
what an ideal client looks like.
So one, they have to
have the budget, right,
whatever range you're in.
So if, for example,
when I deal with brands,
my first brand deal was for $500.
$500 to write a blog post, and I ended up
over delivering, doing
great work for them.
And this is a great example
of I carried them so far,
so I started with $500,
and then we moved it to 750
or something and then 1,000 and then 1,250
and then 1,500, and I moved them from $500
to $1,500 for each post that I was doing,
but that was their cap.
That was their limit,
and I was bringing them
more than $1,500 worth of value every time
I did it, 'cause I put in
so much work and effort.
So eventually, I had to leave them.
Instead of trying to bring
that brand with me up,
I left them, and I brought
on bigger brand deals.
And so understand what is an ideal client.
What do they look like for you?
What budget do they need to have?
What values do they need to have?
If you understand your one
word, and you understand
what values they're looking
for, having a good mash.
Most of the brands that want to work
with me I say no to, because
we're not in alignment.
They just want to sell you guys stuff,
because they don't actually care much
about entrepreneurs,
and if you don't believe
in entrepreneurs, you're not going to be
a good fit for this channel.
I don't want to do a
deal with you, even if
you throw tons of cash at me, because it's
not going to be a good long-term fit.
We're just going to fight
because of values differences.
So understanding the clients
that have the budget,
clients that have the
values, clients that are
doing the work that is
meaningful and important to you,
setting that list of what an ideal client
looks like for you, being
able to identify them,
will help you be able to do
out and get them on board.
(upbeat music)
Tip number three is prove your value.
So once you've found who
these ideal targets are,
you've created your criteria and you've
identified who these people are or who
these brands are or companies are,
I love starting off with a small deal
and then finding a way to make it bigger.
Prove your value.
If nobody knows who you
are, you don't have a name,
you don't have a reputation, you look like
everybody else, prove your value.
If you get in with a low price, with a low
amount of work, right,
like some small project,
then it's easier to get
a yes, and it's easier
to continue on with them.
And so understand that
whatever it is that you do,
a company that you want to work with,
they probably already have
some kind of existing supplier.
They're already working with
people who look like you.
They're working with your
competition in some respect.
And so if you go in and try to pitch,
taking on this huge deal, one, it involves
kicking out your
competition, who they have
an established working relationship with,
and a big deal involves more people
at that company to make a decision.
And so the bigger it is,
the more complicated it is,
the more steps involved, the less likely
you are to get a yes.
What I'd rather do is go into a company
and ask where they're unhappy.
Find one small scenario
where they are unhappy.
So if you're doing website
design, as an example,
instead of trying to take over an entire
company's website, find one landing page.
Like what one landing
page are you unhappy with.
Just give me one thing that you're unhappy
with, that your current
supplier is not doing
a good job with, for whatever reason,
no judgment against them,
you're just unhappy with.
Let me prove my value to you.
And charge them a reasonable
price to do one small project.
Something that is easy
for them to give to you
that one person has to make a decision on,
and you've got your budget to work with,
even though it's a small one.
And then over-deliver like crazy.
Give them so much value.
Be their favorite supplier.
Be the person that then,
whoever you worked with,
saying these guys do such great work,
we should give them more business.
If you do that work, you won't even have
to pitch the other
business, getting the whole
website, because they're
going to be fighting
for you to have that business.
Does it make sense?
The more entrenched you are,
the more value you're providing,
the tighter you build that relationship,
giving them so much more
value than the competition is,
they're going to fight
to give you more work
because they love working with you.
And so, too often, people come in
and they pitch these huge ideas
when nobody knows who they are,
and it's just so complicated a deal
and takes too many steps that you're
not going to get a yes.
Well, if you go in with some
easy-to-say-yes-to decision,
and then you over deliver like crazy,
you're going to get more
and more and more work.
But make sure it's with an ideal client.
(upbeat music)
Tip number four is figure out
the why of your customers.
This is super important.
In a competitive world,
where a lot of people
are trying to under-price each other,
the ultimate way to
win over your customers
is by understanding why
they're coming to you
in the first place.
So here's what happens at our school.
Whenever clients come
into TDS, one of the first
questions they ask is
how much are the classes.
What I make sure to do is ask them why
they're interested, before
we even talk about pricing.
If I can figure out their why,
whether it's to make friends, to be more
comfortable with their
body, whatever it is,
I can tailor my conversation around that.
And what happens then is, price
doesn't become as important,
because, ultimately, people will pay a lot
more for a product that
addresses their needs,
their deep-down desires.
So if you spend a couple extra minutes
to figure out the why of your customers,
you'll be able to charge
them what you're worth
and, ultimately, have loyal customers.
(upbeat music)
Number five is over-deliver
like crazy, and I touched
on it in point number three.
It's really important that
once you get in the door
that you are doing everything you can
to be remembered and
just providing so much
insane value to help them.
And what you want to think about is what
skills do I have, what people do I know
that can help make this
project just so much better?
And so, as an example,
things that I've done.
In that first blog post
that I had $500 for,
my very first brand
deal, all they wanted was
300 words for a blog post that they're
going to post on their site.
And so I didn't just write 300
words and give them content,
I wrote 1,500 words, something like that,
and I give them the
longest article that they
ever had for their blog.
I made a video that was
custom for that post.
I promoted it to my newsletter list
and let my audience
know to go check it out.
And they hired me, and they hired nine
other influencers, so
there was 10 of us total
for this project, and I was the only one
that they picked to continue on with.
Why, because my content got more impact,
got more results, more
engagement, more views
than all of the other nine combined,
because I gave them so much more value.
And so any time a
customer's asking for this,
you want to give them this.
But then you also want
to give them more, right?
Using your skills, your
resources, your connections,
your knowledge to give them
more than what they asked for.
That's how you over deliver.
That's how you can start
raising your prices.
That's how you can start getting more
business within the organization.
And so maybe you know somebody that can
help that company out,
maybe you can connect
two people together,
two companies together,
where there's an interaction
that's mutually beneficial.
Maybe you can provide
a video or go longer.
Always think about the baker's dozen.
13 is the baker's dozen.
So you buy 12 of something,
you get the 13th one for free.
What can you add in that is
unexpected value for them?
Help them in any way possible.
Cover them on your website.
Be a testimonial for them on LinkedIn.
Whatever it is.
Showcase their stuff.
Follow them on Twitter
and retweet their things
and be engaged, because I guarantee you,
no other supplier they're
working with is doing this.
And this is your chance to stand out.
You get some small,
easy-to-say-yes-to deal,
and you provide just so much value to them
that they want to find
ways, they will fight
for ways to continue working with you.
(upbeat music)
Tip number six is keep
increasing your pricing.
So I'm a big fan as you get better,
as you understand how to add more value,
as you improve your skillsets and you
can bring more value to the table,
that you continue to
increase your pricing.
The way I do it on my YouTube channel,
as an example, since you
guys are watching is,
I can only work with so
many brands at a time.
And usually I'll work on annual deals.
So a brand works with me, it will be
for at least a year.
And because I can only work with so many
brands at a time, every
time I get a new brand,
I increase the price.
There's limited supply.
We can only do so many.
So okay, for you it's this, and now,
next time it's this, next time it's this.
And I did the same thing
before I was doing YouTube,
when I was just having my website and my
blog and my newsletter list.
I would send one newsletter out a week,
maximum, that would be in
partnership with a brand.
So there's only four a
month that could happen.
So I'd sell the first one at $1,500
and the second one maybe at $1,500.
Now, my space is getting limited.
So okay, the next one's at $1,750,
and the next one's at $2,000.
And if somebody falls
off, then the next one's
going to be at $2,250.
So as your supply goes down,
you start increasing your prices.
As your value goes up, as you know more,
you can bring more to your clients,
you start increasing your prices.
Where a lot of times,
entrepreneurs just stay stuck
in the same zone for many years charging
the same price, even
though they're bringing
way, way, way more value.
As you bring more value, you start raising
your prices alongside it.
(upbeat music)
And tip number seven, this is one of my
favorite, is to be a thought leader.
If you are so great at what you do,
showcase your expertise.
Be a thought leader so that people will
find you, so you are not out having to do
cold emails or cold tweets or cold calls
or go to events and
congresses and conventions
to try to make connections.
Be a thought leader to
have people find you.
See, when people hire thought leaders,
they're willing to pay more.
If they're bringing on
somebody who they think
is the expert at this
field, they're going to
be willing to pay more.
They're seeking you out
because you are the leader.
If somebody's only going to hire somebody
based on price, they're not going to look
at who's speaking at these events,
who's writing the white
papers, who's being
interviewed on the
different YouTube channels.
It's just a different mindset.
The people who want the value,
the people who want fast results
are people who appreciate the people
who are bringing the results to them,
they seek those people out.
And they pay premium
dollars for those people.
So the way to get that
is to expose yourself.
Be a thought leader.
Share your opinions.
Share your expertise.
Anytime a reporter is
talking about a subject
that is in your field, write
to them and give your opinion.
Share your expertise.
You could be a resource for them.
Reporters are always looking for people
to comment on articles.
They always need industry expertise.
That could be you.
That's how I got into New York Times
and all these other
publications and all these
lists of speakers and thought leaders
and SEO experts and social
media experts to follow,
because I did a lot of work
connecting with reporters.
Put out great content.
Start a YouTube channel.
Start a Twitter account.
Whatever it is that your expertise is,
you'd rather write,
you'd rather make video,
you'd rather do audio, you need to spend
time being a media company and sharing
your expertise to be
seen as a thought leader
so that people will find you, and you can
start turning people down.
When I look at brand deals,
there's platforms out there where you
can bid on working with a brand, right?
Famebit is one, as an example.
Brands will post a
deal, say we have $1,000
to work on this deal,
and all these different
creators will bid on it.
You have no leverage in that situation.
You're one of hundreds of creators bidding
on a project, and it's
just a race to the bottom.
I'm willing to do it for this.
I'm willing to throw in this for free.
You compete against so many people,
and the brand has all the power,
where when I'm creating content,
and the brands come to me,
I'm the one who has the power.
I'm the one who can set the pricing.
I'm the one who can dictate the terms,
because they're coming to me.
And so that's what I
want to create for you.
I want people to come to you,
to find you, to reach out to you,
because you are the thought
leader expert in the field.
And chances are you already know it.
If you're an entrepreneur, you should be
good at what you do.
You already have the
knowledge, but you're only
helping a select group of people,
where if you're making that more public,
and you're sharing what's
already in here out there,
you're going to attract people who value
that expertise, and they'll
pay you top dollar for it.
So those are my seven tips, seven ways
on how to get clients aboard
with value-based pricing.
I'd love to know what did you guys love
about this video?
What was the biggest take-away for you?
Is there an eight, nine,
10 that you want to
add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to thank Mihovil
for asking for this topic.
I made this video because
of him and his request.
If you guys have a request that you'd
like me to make a future
seven ways video on,
check the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Katie Kruse.
Katie, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word and making that
video on your YouTube channel.
I really, really, really appreciate it,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(logo swooshing)